كانت طائرة
بوينج 757 التي يحملها دونالد ترامب رمزًا للمكانة النهائية.
لقد قضى وقتًا
ممتعًا في
حملة عام 2016 في أحداثه البارزة ، وكان هناك
طائرته
التي لم يكن لديهم أي شخص يمتلكها
من قبل من قبل من رالي إلى كنتاكي
اليوم.  تجلس الطائرة العملاقة
مهجورة في شمال مطار نيويورك ،
ويفقد محرك واحد في الغالب ملفوفًا
خاملاً
في حالة سيئة على ما يبدو وفقًا
للسجلات التي لم يتم نقلها منذ شهور
، حيث كانت جالسة على المنحدر
لمدة عام أو عامين على الأقل
والمحرك الأيسر به  تم إقلاعها على
الأرجح
للخدمة ، جوهرة تاج أسطول ترامب في
المستقبل
غير معروف تكلفة الإصلاح ، كما يقول أحد
خبراء الطيران
في الأرقام الستة ، إذا لم يكن هناك المزيد من
هذا المحرك الذي خرج
للخدمة ، فسيحتاج إلى أي شيء يمكن أن
يتراوح من 100 منخفضة  ألف
دولار إلى ما يقرب من مليون دولار إذا
كان لا بد من استبدال أحد الأصول التي يبدو أن ترامب يضعها
على الهامش
وعلى الرغم من أنه من غير الواضح
سبب تأسيسها  في الوقت الذي
تكبدت فيه بعض أعماله خسائر ، كانت في الحقيقة
طائرة قديمة
اشتراها ترامب في عام 1991 في عام
2010.
هناك ما يزيد قليلاً عن
ألف من هذه الطائرات التي تم
بناؤها وجميعها تقريبًا خارج
الخدمة  في الوقت الحالي ، يقول
فيلم وثائقي عن
الطائرة إنه دفع مائة مليون
دولار مقابل عرض
757s مماثلة بسعر السوق
من حوالي
سبعة إلى عشرة ملايين ، لكن ترامب خدعها
ليغطي كل سطح معدني من
إبزيم حزام الأمان إلى الباب  مقابض
حتى الحنفيات من الذهب عيار 24 ،
سعرها 250000 لذلك فقط
وفقًا لشركة التصميم الداخلي
التي جهزت الطائرة بأكملها
بمقاعد أفضل ألواح السقف الجلدية
وقلادات العائلة الرابحة المطرزة من الجلد المدبوغ الكريمي في أقمشة خيوط ذهبية يتم
نقلها من باريس حسب الطلب
من  من غرفة النوم الرئيسية
إلى غرفة الطعام الخاصة على
درب الحملة في عام 2016 ، كانت الطائرة هي
أداة التسويق النهائية
والرمز الملموس لنجاح ترامب
واعدًا بأنه يمكن أن يفعل الشيء نفسه
للبلد
عندما أسافر على متن تلك الطائرة الكبيرة ، فأنا أدفع
ثمنها وراء الكواليس
نفقات مذهبة ولمدة أربع سنوات في
البيت الأبيض مع
إمكانية الوصول إلى القوة الجوية الأولى ، تم إيقاف طائرة 757